bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
émission de tchekhov votre magazine
santé bien-être ce mois ci nous
parlerons de la grippe avec les médecins
et formations cette saison n'échappe pas
à la règle
une campagne de vaccination est déjà
lancé mais tout d'abord le dossier de ce
nouveau numéro le mois d'octobre était
consacré à une lutte celle contre le
cancer du sein
aujourd'hui une femme sur huit est
confronté à ce cancer en cours de sa vie
c'est presque douze mille décès par an
en france
heureusement c'est aussi une maladie qui
se soigne bien si elle est détectée
rapidement nous avons rencontré laurence
et gaël toutes les deux ont eu un cancer
du sein à l'âge de 38 ans l'une est
guéri l'autre est en rémission totale
depuis peu les deux amis ont accepté de
nous parler de leur parcours et de nous
raconter comment elle se reconstruise
aujourd'hui gaël et laurence ont dix ans
d'écart
et pourtant qu'un parcours similaire un
parcours parsemé d'obstacles et pas des
moindres à 38 ans les deux versaillais
apprennent qu'elles sont atteintes d'un
cancer du sein à l'époque elles ont déjà
deux enfants et souhaitent en avoir un
troisième ici aux couleurs d'octobre
rose les deux amis se retrouvent toutes
les semaines pour un cours de zumba
occasion pour elle de se retrouver de se
vider la tête
nous retrouvons gaël chez elle à 39 ans
elle est en rémission totale depuis peu
autrement dit sa maladie est sous
contrôle gaël est suivi depuis l'âge de
25 ans car sa mère a eu un cancer du
sein comme elle a 38 ans lorsqu'elle en
est décédé cinq ans après gaël avait
alors 17 ans c'est sous sa douche un
matin là les dernières qu'elles sont une
boule dans son sein gauche
le verdict est tombé rapidement il va
falloir attendre un peu pour lancer une
troisième grossesse après un an de
traitement lourd contre les tumeurs et
une ablation du sein
gaël a aujourd'hui repris le travail à
temps partiel le sport aussi trois
quatre fois par semaine
moi j'avais vraiment cette image là nous
tunnel donc et je me disait regarde
regarde au bout du tunnel
il fait beau il fait chaud il ya du
soleil tu vas y arriver
voilà la maladie fait peur les amis des
connaissances sont très parfois très
gênés ils savent pas comment réagir
moi j'ai continué à vivre j'ai continué
à voir mes amis j'ai continué à voir ma
famille
et toute l'énergie positive qu'on peut
vous transmettrai les bonnes à prendre
le cancer change pas fondamentalement
votre vie en revanche si vous change
vous donc je j'évacue toutes les
personnes négatives je veux plus je
prends beaucoup de recul par rapport à
certaines situations jeu je suis dans
l'instant il faut savoir est dans
l'instant donc parfois c'est tout simple
on s'est regardé ses enfants jouer c'est
se balader sait faire le sport c'est
profiter des plaisirs de la vie et ce
qui a fondamentalement changé s'écrivait
patera alors être extrait de ce serait
vous montrer ou aimable et yuma bulma
bull
tu sais pas où tu sais plus et petit à
petit gars elle se reconstruit une phase
importante ce qu'il faut savoir bien
gérer
on va laisser aussi le la normalité
revenir parce qu'en fait il ya une chose
qui est très importante c'est que quand
vous êtes malade vous avez plein de gens
autour de vous que ce soit la famille
mais surtout les médecins vous êtes très
entourées vous avez rendez-vous guerre
régulier vous avez des bilans dès que
vous avez déjà vous avez des bilans du
fait de la chimiothérapie et tout ça ça
crée quelque part une dynamique et quand
les traitements s'arrête et bien pour
vous retrouver tout seul alors les
autres familles restent proches de vous
mais je veux dire les gens sont rassurés
ils vous savent en rémission
vous n'avez plus votre rendez vous avec
votre homologue donc là on angoisse un
peu on a mal à la tête on se dit ah là
là ça y est qu'est ce qu'il m'arrive on
est fatigué on se dit bon est ce que
c'est ce qui a pas un signe derrière
tout ça donc il faut reprendre confiance
en soi
et c'est un exercice qui est pas évident
on
si gaël est encore sous traitement avec
des cachets tous les matins et des
piqûres régulière son amie laurence elle
en a fini avec la maladie
c'était il y a dix ans parce qu'elle a
eu des antécédents dans sa famille son
gynécologue lui impose une mammographie
lorsque laurence veut mettre en route
son troisième bébé
résultat un cancer du sein impalpable
après quatre ans de traitement à une
ablation du sein
à 42 ans elle entame sa grossesse et
donne naissance à oscar âgé de 5 ans
aujourd'hui ça à penser qu'on peut
donner c'est des deux quand on est au
début de sa maladie d'arrêter de
chercher pourquoi du parce que parce que
on sera jamais pourquoi on a eu un
cancer et c'est vraiment une perte de
temps il faut absolument se comment dire
se donner un chemin hyper positif et je
dirais que la force on la trouve en nous
vraiment c'est petit à petit voilà
l'image toujours l'image du train avec
c'est avec ces étapes avec ses wagons
voilà on avance on avance chaque pas
chaque jour un pas et puis et puis on va
y arriver
c'est quoi ça c'est si tu sais frénésie
cd peut en parler autour de soi mais
faut le regard haut ma pauvre ça c'est
insupportable c'est pas possible
donc c'est non parce que je pense que
quand on est dans la maladie on n'est
pas du tout on la voit enfin c'est pas
je pense que je le sais on ne la voit
pas du tout de la même façon que ceux
qui n'y sont pas on la voit de façon
plus positive
bon un peu un peu négatif de trace en
temps mais quand même de façon je pense
qu'on a moins peur que ceux qui ne sont
pas dans la maladie qui sont en fait un
peu impuissants ils sont après la
maladie
laurence se sont métamorphosés on voit
pas tout en rose mais
mais ces essais je crois que on aime la
vie on aime la vie à 200 % on a envie de
faire plein de trucs et et c'est c'est
formidable comme elle
chaque année en france près de cinquante
mille femmes apprennent qu'elles sont
atteintes du cancer du sein
l'euro c'est gaël avait des antécédents
familiaux
du coup la mammographie est intervenue
plus tôt pour elle mais c'est surtout
entre 50 et 74 ans que les femmes ont le
plus de risques
détecté tôt le cancer du sein peut être
guéri dans 9 cas sur 10 nous sommes
allés à la rencontre de la troupe
réactive théâtre attrape les acteurs
sensibilise les femmes justement au
dépistage
j'ai reçu l'avis six mois au rêve et à
la maman
j'arrive pas y aller tellement dû faire
des résultats
j'aime éviction m'annonce que j'ai un
cancer pourrait pas dans cette histoire
soria a perdu sa mère elle est décédée
d'un cancer du sein la jeune femme doit
se faire dépister régulièrement mais la
pearl en empêche
une histoire dans laquelle bon nombre de
femmes pourraient se reconnaître
la troupe réactive théâtre joue sur des
thèmes de société en intégrant le
spectateur à la pièce c'est le principe
du théâtre forain but vainqueur soria
vous avez vu on a laissé ouvert parce
qu'elle va continuer à en parler ou pas
à votre avis dans le public gisèle à une
idée une tante pourrait venir en aide à
cette femme qui a peur du dépistage est
quelqu'un de ma famille on essaie de
coller à la réalité pour que les
personnes se sont directement finalement
concerné par ce problème
on n'est pas des professionnels de santé
et mais on croit en une chose c'est que
en parler et communiquer peut sauver des
vies donc en l'occurrence de faire le
dépistage de
graphie ça peut sauver une vie c'est
toujours dans dans une quête de prévenir
le spectacle a remué certains souvenirs
gisèle à perdre une de ses tantes il ya
plusieurs années décédé d'un cancer du
sein en afrique
le dépistage est arrivé trop tard au
début quand ça a commencé et que la dame
avait dit qu'elle avait des douleurs
dans ses selles tous et on en fait on
m'avait fait rappeler c'est que j'avais
pris déjà dans le passé
voilà ma tante a vécu j'étais beaucoup
triste c'est de la vie courante
j'ai appris des choses j'ai appris deux
choses je sais pas que c'était gratuit
je savais pas du temps et plus avec ça
je pense que je parle à l'hôpital et
plus de monde me fait dépister à
l'initiative notamment des quatre
centres socioculturels de trappes et de
la mutualité française ile-de-france ce
spectacle veut amener les femmes à
s'impliquer davantage pour le dépistage
du cancer du sein
elles savent trouver les mots donc mieux
que nous des professionnels de santé
pour convaincre
on voulait donc indirectement leur dire
c'est vous qui êtes capable de
promouvoir le dépistage auprès des
autres femmes est donc là ça a
fonctionné
le but est atteint aujourd'hui bien
qu'elles soient gratuites et accessibles
à partir de 50 ans un peu moins d'une
femme sur deux accepte de passer une
mammographie de contrôle
le taux de vaccination contre la grippe
est en perpétuelle chute
en cause notamment les inquiétudes
suscitées par le vaccin contre
l'épidémie h1n1
si pourtant loin d'être une maladie
anodine la caisse primaire d'assurance
maladie a lancé une campagne nationale
de communication
un reportage de wilfrid richy justement
ghsr de la femme ainsi j'ai acheté un
vaccin pour me faire vacciner ça va être
la toute première fois que je me fais
vacciner
ils ne sont pas nombreux comme cette
femme à faire le choix de la vaccination
contre la grippe seulement 50% des
français dits à risque femmes enceintes
personnes âgées en surpoids ou
asthmatiques se protège régulièrement
contre une maladie qui entraîne pourtant
6000 décès chaque année en france
il est très difficile d'avoir des
chiffres précis on estime dans le monde
que c'est à peu près un demi million de
personnes par an quand même en france
c'est probablement quelques dizaines de
milliers de personnes qui meurent chaque
année des conséquences de la grève donc
ça vaut largement un coup de dé protéger
en général la grippe se caractérisent
souvent par des températures assez
élevées et une survenue très brutal un
site la présence de douleurs musculaires
et c'est contre les idées reçues qui
faut lutter le plus souvent non le
vaccin ne donne pas la grippe et oui une
nouvelle vaccination est nécessaire tous
les ans en raison des mutations du virus
dans cette pharmacie on constate tout de
même que le message commence à passer
je vais pas regarder mes stocks mais
sorti mais vu quand j'ouvre le
réfrigérateur parce que les vacances
card au réfrigérateur
quand je regarde je pense que j'en ai
vendu plus que l'année dernière 10 à 20%
de plus le vaccin coûte à peine plus de
six euros remboursés à 70%
il est gratuit pour les personnes à
risque notamment celles de plus de 65
ans 225000 assuré dans les yvelines ont
ainsi reçu un bon de prise en charge
il faut attendre une quinzaine de jours
après la piqûre pour être immunisé
ce numéro de check up touche à sa fin
avant de nous quitter
jetons un coup d'oeil sur l'agenda et
sur ce qu'il faut retenir du 3 au 5
décembre prochain ce sera la troisième
édition des rencontres de l'autonomie
pour la première fois des ateliers
seront ouverts au public et de le 18
novembre des bus d'information vont
sillonner l'agglomération
le week end des 6 et 7 décembre ce sera
la 27e édition du téléthon un week end
entier consacré au combat contre les
maladies rares
des manifestations seront organisées
dans tout le département check up c'est
terminé merci de votre attention je vous
donne rendez-vous dans un mois
d'ici là portez vous bien
à